[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and you're
watching "The Developer Show,"
here, on-site at
Google I/O 2016.
In this video, we're going to
be taking a look at the Search
APIs.
So Mihai, I'd like to talk
to you about two things.
The first of which
is Rich Cards,
and the second is app indexing.
Now, first I want to take a look
at the documentation for Rich
Cards.
Can you get us
started by telling me,
well, what is a Rich Card?
MIHAI IONESCU: Sure.
So, a Rich Card is
a new visual format
to present search results in an
interactive and engaging way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really awesome.
Pretty much what it means is
that, I search for something,
and instead of just
getting a blue link,
I see information
there in a rich way.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes, yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And you can do
this with markup in your web
page .
So when you're
building your template,
you also just build the
template for markup as well.
So Google knows what it is.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So let's actually take a
look at the documentation,
which we recently updated.
And it's really cool.
You can see the
example in a gallery,
take a look at the
code, validate it,
and see an example of
what it would look like.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Can
you show us that?
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
So in this case, we
have a recipe example.
On the right side, it
shows how the recipes
would appear in a carousel.
We can have a quick
look at the markup.
And the markup in
this case is JSON-LD.
Schema.org offers different
ways to show metadata.
JSON-LD is something
we usually recommend.
You can put your information
in the Schema.org fields
in this format.
When you want to
test it, you can
click on the Validate button.
It will show you, in this
case, hey, we have no errors,
no warnings.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's convenient.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's
very convenient.
We have a lot of
information covered here.
Usually, just a few
fields are required.
But the more you add, the
richer the Card will look like,
and the higher the
chances the user
will interact with the
Card and will go on
to visit your website.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: So more
conversions for you.
So once we have this, we can
go ahead and preview the Card.
And this is how your Card will
look on the search results.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So easy.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
And you can see it has more
than just a small snippet
in the link.
You have a picture.
You have a rating.
You have stuff that's very
specific to the Schema.org type
you're using here.
In this case, the recipe.
It shows that it's
only 230 calories.
So that's a pretty
good piece of pie.
It only takes three
hours to make.
And it has very good reviews.
So as a website
owner, I'm really
happy that this shows preeminent
in the search results.
I'm sure people
will click on this.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm getting
hungry just looking at it.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So I have a search here
for a fried chicken recipe.
At the top of the
search results,
we have what we call a
summary carousel that
shows fried chicken recipes
from all around the web.
And as we talked
before, each card
gives you some
interesting information,
like how long it takes to
cook the recipe, some ratings,
and reviews.
Another way to show
in search results
is through what we
call a host carousel.
Your site-- your cooking
site, or your recipe site--
has a lot of related recipes,
in this case, fried chicken.
Then we group all
of them together.
And we show them for
your site in particular.
In this case, the Food
Network, of course,
they have a lot of
fried chicken recipes.
You can show them in
the host carousel.
So there's a lot of information
that users can browse, and then
decide to go and
visit your website.
So app indexing is a way to
add your app in the search
results, same way you have you
website in the search results.
So we offer an API that
you can use and have
your app indexed by Google.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Let's see a demo.
Show me what it looks like.
MIHAI IONESCU: So let's see.
You're traveling,
and you're in Japan.
You want to find
a hotel in Tokyo.
You find the familiar
search results.
If you scroll down
a little bit, you'll
actually see that you have
the Booking.com app installed.
And it provides a link to
the 30 best hotels in Tokyo.
If you click on it, this link--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It goes
right into the app.
MIHAI IONESCU: So we are now
inside the Booking.com app.
There is a nice
listing of hotels
with a lot of information.
You browse through it.
After a while, you come back.
And you, of course,
don't remember the link.
But you can just type Tokyo
or start typing Tokyo.
And you see, because you
already visited the app,
another nice feature of--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
It's right there.
MIHAI IONESCU: --app
indexing is autocompletion.
We have a link to
properties in Tokyo.
You click on it, you go
back exactly where you were.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's another
great benefit of app indexing.
And I want to show
you one more thing.
Let's say, oh, there's
so much stuff out there.
I want to see
another booking app.
What other booking
apps are out there?
So you just type here,
hotel booking apps.
And let's see how many
apps are app indexed.
Well, quite a lot of them.
It will provide a nice
matrix of hotel booking apps.
Booking.com is one of
them, but of course, you
can try another one.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
very cool, Mihai.
Thank you so much for the demo
of both Rich Cards and app
indexing.
And for everybody
there at home, please
check the description
below for the links
to demos and documentation
of everything
we just talked about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]